bon alors on à gad elmaleh justement au
téléphone j'ai gad à l'eau on entendra
loïc had gad et avec ce week end
allô allô oui gad oui comment ça va ça
va être mon gars doux j'écoute je vous
regarde
je sais je sais que tu as et sûrs du
fait d'un homme je sais je sais que tu
as été touchés gars parce que si c'est
dès ce week-end
t'as quoi répondre à ceux qui disent que
ce sketch et est raciste mais le
problème est déjà non mais charlieu
chevannes une interview comme je veux
déjà exigé gad elmaleh au téléphone
j'aimerais déjà lui demander déjà qu'on
parle du skate qui a comparé leur à d
autres choses déjà en caisse que tu peux
dire gad à ceux qui disent que ce sketch
est raciste
d'abord j'ai envie de dire à ceux qui le
trouve pas drôle que suffisant droit et
qu'elle est chantée trouve drôle ou pas
drôle et ça vraiment j'ai aucun problème
avec ça et ça je peux citer plein de
sketches et des chez nous je suis
humoriste mais se cache qu'ils ont droit
trouvait drôle ou pas drôle mais là où
il ya un malentendu et c'est ce qui me
dérange aujourd'hui ce qui ce qui me
touche c'est qu'il ya il ya un énorme
malentendu sur ce qu'on a voulu faire
dans ce sketch se dire qu'il a pu
volontairement sur des clichés
il n'y a aucune malice ya aucune
intention de blesser communauté on
ridiculise les clichés s'est même mise
en abyme
c'est presque un sketch sur un skate sur
les asiatiques tabac loin quand même si
un sketch dans lequel je dis qu'elle tue
la famille d'ailleurs l'extrait où je
dis c'est limite raciste on peut pas
faire ça imaginez des chiffons l'année
au gabon alors voilà un gars tu te rends
compte si si j'avais dû me faire
attaquer par les marocains les québécois
les blonds les homosexuels mon sketch et
bastien on sait bien que les français ne
parlent pas tous comme le père de
théâtre a qu'un on sait bien que donc
donc c'est là qu'il ya un malentendu
mais pour autant ça veut dire que
j'entends pas je suis pas fou j'entends
ce qui se passe c'est la raison pour
laquelle je te demande mais je sais mais
ce soir je pense qu'il se passe moi je
suis humoriste j'ai pas envie de blesser
personne j'ai absolument pas envie mais
me faire traiter de raciste pour moi
qui suis je pense le seul artiste quelle
carte de séjour dans ce pays
c'est vrai c'est pas mal c'est vraiment
pas ça m'a choqué ça m'a damas hama
comment dire ça m'a piqué et je veux
entendre à ce que ce que ce que les gens
à me dire intense papa de de la haine
sur les réseaux sociaux et ça on est
tous victimes de ça quand on est
publique aujourd'hui ce que j'entends
c'est qu'il ya des gens qui ont été
réellement blessé et les messages
d'ailleurs auquel j'ai vraiment prêté
attention c'est ce qui était serein
éclairé ouvert de jeunes asiatiques qui
ont écrit voilà en gros j'ai plus la
teneur des messages mais en gros qu'est
ce que tu fous ta merde et on te suit
depuis des années qu'est ce que t'as
foutu nous déçoit enfin ça ça m'a
beaucoup blessé ça m'a beaucoup à sa
table et c'est ça ma femme a atteint ça
m'a peiné qu'ils soient déçus et j'ai
envie de reparler et ce soir j'ai envie
de leur dire que ça a mal entendu
ce soir j'ai envie de dire à tous ces
gens qui pensent que on a fait un sketch
contre ou qui a eu je sais pas une
malice un détournement de propos c'est
faux c'est pas notre intention c'était
pas ça et il ya les humoristes autour de
la table ce soir même si j'entends le
produit en lui qu'il a raison sur le
fait que c'est compliqué parce que on a
droit peut-être plus facilement de créer
deux communautés malgré ça je dis qu'on
a fait un sketch sur un skate c'est une
caricature on est obligé de prendre des
clichés on est obligé de prendre des
gros traits pour pouvoir après bouger
les lignes les déplacés et s'en moquer
alors ce que ce que te reprocher aussi
jean-luc sais que tu as décidé de faire
la promotion autour du skate des chinois
prenant parti la djette est ce que là tu
trouves que tu trouves pas que tu as un
peu loin là dessus gadoue où tu tu
reviens pas là dessus c'est une erreur
ah bon c'est une erreur parce que ouais
oui je pense que le général parce qu en
fait j'aurais dû privilégier le dialogue
avec elle en plus tôt que ton blanc le
leur sentiment mais je vais très bien et
vous moins qu'en juillet la tribune que
je fais je m'achèterai que de raciste
parce épidermique je deviens fou je me
moi moi je trouve dans par les dieux du
racing très bien de ce que je suis
depuis des années même sur la sociaux
donc de me faire traiter de raciste par
quelqu'un d'une autre communauté en plus
tu étais plus tôt mais en anglais on
n'est plus ensemble ya un vrai problème
tam appliquer sa main et alors j'ai fait
le cargo souhait j'ai envoyé des tweets
pour la
à réagir oui alors ce maladroit alors
alors oui oui là là là je suis je pense
que j'aurais pas dû faire ça d'ailleurs
si elle nous regarde je m'adressais à ce
soir jeudi pardon
louise puisqu'à la ramenant de d'avoir
été maladroit là dessus parce que ce
n'était pas ça que je voulais et
jean-luc ça s'appelait la réponse de gad
là bas je trouve ça très bien parce
qu'en plus moi j'ai beaucoup de respect
et d'admiration pauvres pour gad et tout
et je trouve que c'est quelque chose qui
lui ressemble pas et voilà moi ce que je
comprenais pas c'était justement
pourquoi dans ce coup le sketch il joue
avec les clichés c'est pas ça qui me
choque le plus c'était plutôt la
communication la semaine dernière c'est
ce qui va élire koné qui a fait une
erreur
pour ce qui me concerne excuses
acceptées et puis voilà pas de souci
riga est ce que tu as un dernier mot
pour pau pour la fin on regarde tu as tu
un dernier message à faire passer
je sais pas je encore une fois j'ai
envie de dire et encore une fois je
parle pas de la haine on comptait public
qui reçoit la haine tous les jours tu
reçois des quatre mines ampleur pas
possible il faut un peu différemment
dans ce qui est excessif turin ça
devient vraiment dérisoire abandonné
mais j'ai envie de dire aux gens qui
m'ont écrit de manière éclairée de
manière super sincères qui sont des gens
qui font partie de la communauté
asiatique et qui m'ont dit gad qui suit
arrive ce soir j'ai envie de leur dire
les gars moi je suis avec vous dans le
combat ventura si je suis là dedans on
parle des mêmes choses que je veux je
peux même des rencontres et je peux même
en parler je nomme je suis très même
entendre en fait finalement ce qui les a
blessés parce que le sketch il est drôle
et pas drôle ça c'est pas moi c'est un
humoriste je fais ça depuis des années
mais j'ai envie de leur dire ce soir je
suis avec vous et le racisme s'est
taillé à part un racisme en compte les
juifs 1 contre les asiatiques un contrat
alors peut-être se dit jean-luc je
l'entends aussi parce qu'il peut être à
un moment donné on n'a pas donné autant
d'importance aussi au racisme anti
asiatique et jus et hutin je viens en
france georges juge
je suis un citoyen je sais ce qui se
passe je sais qu'il ya du racisme anti
asiatique je suis calé d'événements je
suis pas fou je suis pas mais ce que
j'ai envie de leur dire c'est je suis
avec vous dans ce [ __ ]
combat contre le racisme en tant
qu'immigré déjà dans ce pays et en tant
que voix en tant qu'artiste en tant
qu'humain donc voilà je suis avec vous
quand je me fais taire sa fille je suis
piquée voilà gadoullet de bien c'est
très très classe que tu as fait ce soir
en tout cas de vouloir d'exprimer et de
prendre la parole et de t'excuser je
trouve ça vraiment ça dénote une grande
classe merci garde d'avoir été avec nous
on t'aime fort et on espère que tout va
s'arranger en tout cas est vraiment
merci de nous avoir rappelé ce soir et
on a je pense qu'on a tous compris ton
message est vraiment je trouve qu'il
voit la ilaha illa il a cessé
c'est génial vraiment ce que tu avais de
ce soir de d'accepter et de reconnaître
des erreurs
franchement merci gatx fait un énorme
bisou et on t'aime fort merci gâte
d'avoir est avec nous
[Applaudissements]